strich für strich den alltag festhalten
andré sandmann ist an durbans catcher er
zeichnet was in der augenblick
bereithält und die zeit erlaubt bevor
sich der moment verflüchtigt oder er am
ziel ist fertig
seit einigen jahren gibt es die bewegung
der erben skechers auf dem ganzen globus
abgezeichnet wird drinnen oder draußen
nicht fantasie ist gefragt sondern
wirklichkeit
erben skechers wollen flüchtige
begegnungen zeigen scheinbar verborgenes
ihren alltag
fotografiert wurde sind die interessiere
mich am wenigsten festhalten und dann
teilen mit den anderen mitgliedern der
community für erben skechers ein
wichtiger anspruch den das internet
möglich macht 8000 aktive mitglieder hat
der internationale blog die bilder aus
zürich treffen da auf szenen us soul
oder kalifornien
die hofft so wenn es so mit sich selber
beschäftigt sich auch sozial
aber wenn man dann beweise es geht liegt
in andere steht wo genau das gleiche
haben also wo genau sagen wir die nerd
ist hinterher und dass man sich trifft
und austauscht und die ritterschaft
andere gespürt dass ich es extrem
fantastisch vor drei jahren war sandmann
mitbegründer des schweizer blogs
vererben skechers alle paar monate
treffen sich die mitglieder um gemeinsam
abzuzeichnen
eigentlicher begegnungsort bleibt das
internet
die kunst aus dem notizheft wird
öffentlich gemacht doch manchmal braucht
es für die begegnung mit gleichgesinnten
keine digitale welt reise in luzern
bietet die migros klubschule bereits den
zweiten kurs enormen skating an
und einmal wöchentlich treffen sich die
neuen kursteilnehmer um zusammen mit
lehrer aus lauber abzuzeichnen
die kulissen mit dem stift festzuhalten
die normalerweise fotografiert werden
ramacher 35 das friedhofs kriecher durch
konzentrieren und keine hilfe sie vor
der proportionen
aber eigentlich ist abzeichnen ja keine
neue entdeckung bereits goethe hier
seine italienreise mithilfe skizzierte
bilder fest und ried weniger zu sprechen
dafür mehr zu zeichnen
noch hielt er im spiegel genau dann
kracht skizzieren nennt sich nun in
sketchen ist trendy geworden und bringt
verborgenes zum vorschein
und plötzlich stumpf zwar schnell klappt
das schon auf dem immer schneller werden
als gegenpol zum flüchtigen zum
inflationären handy bild zum planlosen
abknipsen verso s ist nicht nur wichtige
bis schnallt konsumieren und möglichst
viel schnell und billig sondern es geht
darum sich zieht
sich zeit nehmen und einsteigen bevor
sich der moment verflüchtigt